a vote on Tuesday on mass surveillance
by Parliament civil liberties committee
or today's resolution is essentially an
update on the mass surveillance inquiry
it takes into account the whole range of
issues but it also illustrates the truth
at the bottom of this that safe harbor
shows that you have all these
interconnected movements of mass data
which depend on good standards of data
protection in the United States as well
as in the EU and now seemingly not so
safe harbor the agreement that allowed
us come is to pass on data of EU
citizens was invalidated after ruling by
the European Court of Justice in October
and modern day David versus Goliath
story where an Austrian law student took
on facebook and one did MEP whose voices
have been largely ignored or data
protection feel vindicated this is going
to be a major commercial headache and we
were warning about this for many years
it you know this is not a matter of us
being vindicated or an issue of politics
this is an issue of the daily lives of
businesses the whole main purpose of the
european union and i hope the parliament
is to make sure that europe the most
competitive block trading bloc in the
world data protection yes but we also
have to make sure that it doesn't wreck
businesses or make life so difficult
that in fact we lose our place in the
world so until the u.s. can hire a new
privacy laws through its courts or
establish and improve to safe harbor
agreement with Europe legal limbo ensues
for us and EU companies not a story that
Facebook will be like ink